also where are the light switches in
your house you call the police so that
was definitely a butterfly effect thing
that we do it may I can see that Amon in
its probably don't was Emily's ponies
playboy no no I just
stay away from Emily oh I saw you in it
I want to say I stayed yeah I think I
saw her as well because the mornings
just in yeah what I saw you in that the
telescope before we just ran into each
other in a while I said hello which one
I only have an issue with it because I
knew Emily lied to him to go it's not
really nice trust it's not my fault
no yeah I apologize yes yeah true right
yeah
sorry it's been kind of a long day I
overreacted nah don't work that cool
yeah
very wide like to everyone the babies
bandy-legged to some rice little horses
are those sixty in on your territory
honey
oh man oh you're gonna put him down no
one else can play with your toys you're
such a [ __ ] whatever she was being all
up at Mike's Emily suggested it was to
try and possess him like to show off to
her really I'm a man [ __ ] is crazy
yeah really bad day
Oh
she's so awful she's phoned to death and
actually she died just for great the
other girl really as well yeah okay
why is she was dating one of her good
qualities I'm not seeing any she's Sam
he's nice
this
so we're still gonna get creepy now I
didn't know whether I wanted to go
outside as everyone to go inside and get
warm and now they're all taking off they
didn't do anything to even get warm I
think that's what he was thinking at
that moment
it wasn't like [ __ ] it's cold I don't
know [ __ ] books on oh it's awful they
look awful you both look terrible
you look like crap it was terrible hey
you capable of intelligent conversation
oh no week in nurses oh my god it's so
cold out here already
I'll take my clothes off ridiculous she
seems to have sex with brutal we should
be stopping why don't you just
don't want me to that eaten by ABARES
not gonna happen when they're
hibernating like oh yeah idiot Jess yeah
so agree Emily was being a [ __ ] distant
yelling Spanish [ __ ] I think that's
can we watch it again don't think so
each other that is the bad guy punching
what is that danger of a threat of a
future danger the thing that I played
him I told you I played a sudden event
was that love it she gets punched in the
face oh don't you wanna see you like
Stephanie the guy will since that's the
bad guy I was the not con victim not
sure victus no Hydra TM the dragon
dragon moving the salesman I've taken
Victor is the dragon obviously all
videos click that part you like it
okay okay
yep we're good I don't react that much
to see you seen it
that's not reactive she using well
there's someone there I think that's
Victor he was a human costume no that
was the generator
sorry
you turn the generator off thanks not
open that gate Electric yeah
it is strange
maybe one day they'll have an
intelligent conversation but today is
not that big they never closed the
investigation getting the creeps now
would you
it's awesome you barely even remember
what happened well what I remember is
that we played a stupid half-baked print
that probably got Hannah and back killed
it's not our fault they ran into the
wood
well I mean that was your fault but yeah
it's not their fault they died no it's
not their fault they don't but you might
well they might has another brain strips
or this he's supposed to be an
intelligent one is yeah it's one of his
traits but I think that woman screaming
to me that sounded like a woman's baby
to me Oh silly it's in with a moon for a
cat we can't
I think you should give a job
they don't know I feel like I would go I
would jump down if I was him I think you
should jump down yeah what's pushing the
top no idea I think that means that
we've changed the outcome they need to
be doing opposite either an option to it
really it's just forward